merci d'avoir été là les Chéries dans un
instant le gros dos people il y a alors
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire c'est un
truc de fou et on a en exclusivité je
vous le dis la réaction de stepphan
plazarusvité puis nous a on a eu son
avocate on a un long texte à vous lire
on va vous lire dans un instant et c'est
la réaction de de Stéphane sur tout ce
qui se dit actuellement pour le moment
on va parler d'une histoire incroyable
et c'est vrai que cette histoire elle
nous a tous rendu fou au bureau
également euh c'est l'histoire de Nadia
Nadia frappé séquestrée humiliée
maltraité durant 7 ans par sa famille
d'accueil c'est une histoire incroyable
ça a fait des des millions de vues son
histoire sur les réseaux elle est avec
nous dans un instant regardez petit
récin
merci pendant plusieurs années Nadia a
vécu un véritable enfer au sein de sa
première famille d'accueil dans cette
famille donc j'ai subi des violences
physiques mais aussi des violences
psychologiques placé dès l'âge de 3 ans
la jeune femme souhaite aujourd'hui
dénoncer les pratiques et les erreurs
des services sociaux j'étais restée avec
ma mère je pense pas que j'aurais été
aussi malheureuse Nadia qui affirme
vouloir se battre pour mener un combat
juridique a immédiatement reçu une vague
de soutien sur les réseaux sociaux après
sa vidéo bouleversante tu peux être fier
de toi d'être aujourd'hui capable d'en
parler frappé séquestré humilié Nadia
maltraitée par sa famille d'accueil nous
raconte le calvaire qu'elle a subi ce
soir dans
TPMP merci merci beaucoup d'être là
merci merci Nadia d'être là euh vous
avez 22 ans vous avez vécu un véritable
cauchemar dans votre famille d'accueil
qui vous a fait subir des violences
physiques morales des séquestrations des
enfermements des humiliations pendant 7
ans euh votre histoire est
incroyable on va on va parler de votre
histoire et si vous nous rejoignez à
20h26 en direct écoutez bien l'histoire
de Nadia qui est vraiment qui nous a
tous
bouleversé on va avancer de façon
chronologique déjà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter comment vous êtes
retrouvé en famille d'accueil à 3 ans
alors j'ai été enlevé de ma mère à l'âge
de 3 ans parce qu'elle elle n'était pas
en Capac cé de s'occuper de moi donc
j'ai été placée dans une première
famille d'accueil de mes 3 ans jusqu'à
mes 10 ans dans cette famille où j'ai
donc subi des violences donc des
violences physiques mais aussi des
violences psychologiques parce que j'ai
été isolée et mais à part de tout le
monde j'ai j'ai pu être enfermé dans une
cave j'ai j'ai reçu des coups jusqu'à
suffocation à signé du nez on venait me
tirer on venait me tirer par les cheveux
de ma chambre tout le long des escaliers
et on me laissa à genou pendant des
heures sur des cailloux dans une petite
pièce où où je pouvais me retrouver à
manger toute seule euh sans contact avec
avec la famille qui qui m'acueillait
vous en parliez à l'école à l'école non
à l'école c'était le seul endroit où où
j'étais où j'étais bien c'est ça ouais
justement comment ça se passait quand
les parents venaient vous chercher à
l'école alors quand la famille venait me
chercher à l'école euh ces familles-là
font font très bien semblant devant
devant tout le monde ils savent faire
faire en sorte que les personnes ne le
voient pas ça qui est fou donc il
venaent me chercher il souriait et à
peine rentrer dans leur voiture je
savais que c'était c'était
reparti vous aviez pas des des des
copains à l'école à qui vous pouviez
parler j'avais une copine mais euh je lu
je parlais pas je pensais pas parler de
ça il y a juste une fois où euh vous
avez fait une fugue avec une copine
voilà un jour je lui ai dit que ça
allait pas et que je voulais fuguer et
euh je ce que j'ai fait j'ai j'ai voulu
fuguer après jeis pas je suis pas j'ai
pas entré dans les détails de de
pourquoi je voulais fuguer donc j'ai
commencé à fuguer et une professeur m'a
rattrapé et euh quand elle m'a elle m'a
demandé pourquoi jeis voulu fuguer je
lui ai pas forcément dit parce que à 8
10 ans on n'est pas on a peur de
raconter et on se rend pas forcément
compte aussi que c'est pas normal donc
euh on m'a convoqué dans le bureau avec
la famille d'accueil qui est venue et
euh donc pareil devant tout le monde
devant les professeurs c'est ben
pourquoi tu fais ça euh on comprend pas
tu sais si quelque chose ne va pas tu
peux nous en parler et euh elle était
venue avec sa fille et euh et après je
suis repartie dans la voiture et ça a
rien changé c'est reparti
et Nadia à à à vos 10 ans euh cette
famille décide de de de séparer de vous
euh il paraît que vous n'avez pas été
tout de suite soulagé de quitter cette
famille parce que donc quand j'ai été
enlevé forcément à 10 ans moi j'ai
grandi là-bas de mes 3 ans jusqu'à mes
10 ans donc c'était un peu la normalité
c'était c'était la famille qui qui m'a
éduqué pendant 7 ans donc j'ai eu mal
mal au cœur en fait quand quand j'étais
enlev parce que c'était j'ai vécu un
abandon un abandon de ma mère et là de
de me faire retirer encore une fois de
de mes repères parce que même s'il
s'occupaient mal de moi c'était mes
repères au début j'ai eu j'ai eu très
mal au cœur mais par la suite je me suis
rendu compte que c'était pas normal
quand j'ai vu que la deuxième famille
d'accueil s'occupait bien de moi en fait
alors ce qui est fou et la question que
doivent se poser tous nos
téléspectateurs ce soir c'est pourquoi
ces familles accueillent des enfants et
a priori pour vous vous dites c'est pour
l'argent comment c'est pour l'argent
qu'ils accueillent ses enfants alors je
pour moi je vois pas d'autres d'autres
raisons parce que si on aime vraiment
son boulot on fait pas ça des enfants
qui qui ont été enlevés déjà j'ai été
enlevé de ma mère parce que j'étais en
danger donc on est censé être dans une
famille qui nous protège qui nous donne
de l'amour qui nous montre ce que c'est
une famille si on aime vraiment ce qu'on
fait parce que pour faire ce boulot faut
aimer ce qu'on fait et et on peut pas le
faire ce boulot enfin on faut pas donner
ce boulot à n'importe qui c'est quand
même c'est je pense qu'il ne m'aimit pas
et qui n'ont aimé aucun enfant qu'ils
ont accueilli justement tu as une
anecdote d'un autre enfant scachier je
crois tu peux nous raconter j'ai un
souvenir d'un petit garçon qui était
accueilli là-bas
euh je j'ai pas tous les souvenirs
autour mais de de juste ce ce moment où
ils l'ont scotché sur un arbre avec du
gros scotch et en fait ça les amusait et
j'ai j'ai plus la suite autour j'ai j'ai
aucun souvenir de ce qui s'est passé
après à côté mais j'ai cette image où
oui il on scotché avec du gros scotch
autour et il était petit on avait
presque le même âge on devait avoir 8
ans 7 8 ans il il y a une autre anecdote
aussi avec une fille plus agâgée que toi
que tu admiré beaucoup alors cette fille
était elle éit là pas longtemps on
était on était à table et je voyais
qu'elle allait pas bien ça se voyait
elle était beaucoup plus grande que moi
elle devait avoir 16 ans et j'ai
remarqué qu'elle allait vraiment pas
bien et je l'ai vu partir avec un
couteau dans les mains
et sur le coup je sais qu'un couteau
c'est pas bien mais on sait pas trop
comment réagir et je l'ai vu son fils
revenir avec donc cette cette cette
fille avec les veines ouvertes et donc
la situation est vraiment triste mais ce
qui m'a marqué c'est que que ils ont
bien ils ont bien réagi ils ont appelé
les pompiers et lorsqu'il la tenait
cette fille a craché sur le visage de la
famille d'accueil et c'est peut-être
bête mais pour moi je la voyais comme
mais elle a de la force elle a fait ça
et moi je j'ai 7 ans je peux rien faire
et elle elle a fait ça et après je l'ai
plus jamais revu mais ça m'a marqué
parce que bah je me suis dit il faut
avoir une force énorme pour pouvoir
faire ça justement à à 7 ans vous avez
eu une opération du cœur oui j'ai je
suis née avec une malformation cardiaque
et donc que j'ai dû venir à Paris me
faire opérer et je suis on m'a déposé en
taxi donc ma famille d'accueil est venue
avec moi en taxi et ils m'ont juste
déposé et ils sont repartis quo quoi à 7
ans vous êtes parti donc faire
l'opération toute seule oui à Paris
toute seule ils ont juste déposé mes
affaires et ils sont repartis ils sont
repartis et je suis restée un mois toute
seule et heureusement qu'il y avait
l'équipe médicale qui était présente
parce que je suis j'étais toute
seule ça va mieux aujourd'hui vous une
opération récemment je croisè j'ai été
opéré une deuxème fois à 17 ans euh
c'est ça va mieux en ce moment mais ça
revient c'est c'est pas guéri à 100 %
c'est
c'est ça va revenir je sais que ça je
vais devoir me refaire opérer je sais
pas quand
mais prochainement aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vous après à l'âge de 10 ans
comme vous nous l'avez dit vous êtes
donc envoyé dans une nouvelle famille
oui et avec eux ça se passait bien alors
dans cette famille complètement
différent c'était complètement différent
je je suis arrivée donc de mes 10 ans
jusqu'à mes 1 ans et demi je n'ai eu
aucune aucune violence après c'est
toujours difficile de trouver sa place
dans une famille d'accueil surtout après
ce que j'avais vécu avant donc euh s
très bien passé je pense que je me suis
senti vraiment épanouie à partir du
moment où où j'ai eu mon indépendance à
mes presque à mes 18 ans euh j'aiété
prise en charge ensuite par une
association m 17 ans et ils m'ont aidé à
avoir un logement audace audace c'est ça
et je remercie beaucoup bra bravo bravo
et il paraît que grâce à ton témoignage
à votre témoignage un un un enfant a été
sauvé oui alors
euh
euh avec mon placement dans ma première
famille d'accueil oui c'est ça oui oui
en alors il y a le petit garçon qui a
été scotché autour de de l'arbre lorsque
je suis arrivée dans ma 2è famille
d'acil oui j'ai averti je j'ai averti
tout de suite qu'il y avait ce petit
garçon qui qui qui est encore là-bas
donc les services sociaux sont
intervenus à l'improviste dans cette
famille et et ont enlevé ont remarqué
que ça se passait mal et ont enlevé le
petit garçon la famille d'accueil ont
plus le droit de travailler pour les
l'aide social à l'enfance du pas de calé
mais ont pu retravailler donc ils ont
déménagé dans le Nord et ont pu
retravailler pour le pour le Nord
incroableroable ils ont juste déplacé
ils ont déplacé il l'argent non mais
c'est c'est fou hein c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est incroyable cette histoire
igile très vite il y a quelque chose qui
me qui me sidère Sid j'ai discuté avec
Nadia je j'en tremble j'en tremble il y
a il y a Nadia elle va mieux récemment
elle a voulu porter plainte elle a été
portter plainte alors vous allez nous
raconter ça dans un instant g parce que
c'est l'histoire vous allez voir ça
continue c'est fou c'est c'est fou vous
allez entendre cette histoire chez vous
qui est qui est absolument incroyable
NAD vous rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans quelques minutes à tout de
suite